I called it the lion diet because it's
not a cool diet and you're a total dweeb
when you're on it you feel like a dweeb
and you're socially weird and it's
really frustrating and you lose all your
favorite foods and you're probably sick
to begin with and I wanted this diet to
have some sort of strong name and be
cooler tried to make it cooler because
being sick sucks and the all beef diet
just sounded so bad so I guess people
might say the lion diet is cringy but I
know that you need a certain amount of
strength in order to combat chronic
disease you need that same kind of drive
to do it without the medical system with
diet because that is so Cutting Edge and
so new that people won't believe you and
you need to be strong and I thought the
lion diet kind of embodied that and
lions only eat meat people are like well
Lions don't eat salt haha are you eating
raw meat like a lion I'm not saying I'm
a lion you nerds just call it the lion
diet